hey man remember Joker did the movie we
just rewatched 10 minutes ago yeah I
remember did you know that joker maybe
isn't as original of a movie as you once
thought oh the famously original movie
about a comic book character film is
actually stylistically and tonally very
similar to a very old movie a movie
directed by Martin scorses things
pronounced Scorsese whatever I'm a bit
of a film nerd I'm a bit of a film geek
there's a term people actually have for
People Like Us cinephile film fans this
movie inspired a lot in joke I would
love it I just would love it if you'd
get to the point the movie that joker is
based on basically
is the king of The Aviator The Aviator
it's a bit of an experimental piece they
have have you never seen the king of
comedy I'm not familiar with it what is
that how have you not seen the king of
comedy and how does Joker have anything
to do with the aviation what was the
point of any of this what are you even
talking about okay man I get it you've
seen movies just be nice to the people
exploring a new fun topic film history
you know you're right you're right I'm
I'm sorry and like we all can learn
something from this skit you know oh
you're doing a fourth wall break Like
the Wolf of Wall Street right is that is
that the Coen Brothers who's that